many Americans are hoping to meet goals
for self-improvement and happiness this
year the Yale professor Laurie Santos
started teaching the class psychology
and the good life last January I want to
enroll ya it became the university's
most popular course no surprise in
person and online 78,000 people for more
than 168 countries have enrolled she
will teach a new session of her free
online course called the science of
well-being Laurie Santos is joining us
now
welcome Happy New Year Happy New Year
you thanks for having you in the show
this sounds like a fascinating class and
a lot of it is based around gratitude
and it's something that we stress I know
during the holidays what can we do to
express gratitude and take it with it
throughout the year part of it is just
realizing that gratitude is really
important you know we have these
gratitude journals and we hear buzzwords
like gratitude but we forget how
powerful it can really be just to think
the people that we care about in our
life one of the interventions we do in
class is called the gratitude letter
when you really just write down what
you're thankful for to a person you
haven't told and research suggests that
just the act of doing that takes 10-15
minutes can boost your positive mood for
over a month and so these are like
really powerful effects again they get a
lot of air time but we forget how
powerful they can really be because you
start to focus on what you really do
have in life instead of thinking about
what I don't have what I want
you start looking for the littles and it
really in life it's the little things
that really add up and make something
very very significant but I've heard in
your class that you say time effluence
plus gratitude plus social connections
equals happiness yeah and these are the
three things that yeah it's about yes so
time affluence is a really foreign
concept especially as we're coming out
of the holiday season it's just the act
of having some free time it's looking at
that calendar and seeing big white
blocks now most of us don't have that
naturally right but the new year is an
awesome time where we can build it in
like you can go to your calendar right
now sometime in January and February and
scribble in these three hours they're
just mine not putting anything in there
and it can just be a powerful technique
that when you roll up on that Wednesday
you're like this is amazing I three
hours free yeah and then send a memo to
your boss and say
you know I've been planning it since
noon but we forget that what
productivity actually relies on not
feeling so time finish like even bosses
should want their employees to have a
few open hours because those open hours
can mean the difference between you know
burning out hours later and just really
feeling like you know you're fresh and
open every day once a month once a week
what do you mean just more than you have
now you know for some of us who have
lots of open time you know we can get a
lot of white time in there you know I'm
a busy professor you guys are busy folks
it might not be that much but you know
even an hour can make a huge difference
one thing we did in the class was that I
gifted students some time they didn't
expect so they came to class one day
just one random Tuesday and I said hey
you guys today there's no class you have
an hour and a half free and what was
amazing is that even these Yale students
some of them were so affected by this
one of the students burst into tears and
she said this was the first free hour
she's had all semester
Wow we love you for sir Santos we call
them snow days arrival of free time yeah
one other thing about gratitude
obviously it gets you to focus as Gayle
said on those things you have but it
also the letter creates a social
connection it keeps you connected on the
right level with people who are around
you and in your life and this is
something we again forget one of the
main things that distinguishes happy
people from not so happy people is that
happy people take time for social
connection they're just physically with
other people they try to make
connections with the people on the
street and they take time for the people
they care about you know often when
we're trying to prioritize all this
stuff we want to do in the new year we
over schedule but we don't include the
people we care most about you know they
come last happy people don't do that and
to mimic happy people just you know make
time for the people you care about what
role is social media playing in our
happiness or lack of happiness well I
think it relates to this point on social
connections social media can be one of
these things that we think is giving us
social connection you know I'm scrolling
my Instagram feed and I'm seeing what
folks wore last night it feels like I'm
connecting but it's a kind of empty
calories sort of connection and and
that's where one of the reasons I think
our young people feel so lonely you know
over 50% of college students report
feeling lonely most of the time and I
think that's in part because they're
getting their social connection through
their phones not physically in presence
with other people so quick tips for
happiness
in 2019 in the new year yeah I think
take gratitude seriously you know really
take time once a month to scribble down
that you're thankful for someone you
really care about take your little white
blocks and your calendar do it now for
February March you'll be happy when
those things come up and just talk to a
stranger on the bus it'll boost your
mood more than using it with others and
what's wrong with you before you started
teaching this class were you a happy
person you know I'm not one of those
folks who's genetically predisposed to
be happy but now that I've taught the
class I have to practice what I preach
you know my students ask me like who did
you write your gratitude letter to so
but as the research suggests like when
you do the techniques you end up
boosting your mood so my self reward
exactly Thank You professor Santos good
to see you thank someone thank you